Should be live here.
I'm not seeing the chat actually.
There we go.
That works. Cool.
Let's just get
get a little bit of clarity here.
This this get rid of this.
This
Okay, this is not going in the right
direction here.
We mostly just have to merge in some M's
and stuff before 50, right?
So, this is a good project to be futing
on for a little while.
nine.
What about this one?
Okay,
we have a couple experiments we can run
There.
went to vacation
later tonight.
Sounds good. I will be streaming a lot
more this week, so we can merge some
stuff in.
But hopefully we have some brain cells
back here today.
At least a few of them.
I've been to Europe and is I've been up
to a lot of places in Europe. I find it
mostly overrated.
I've been to London. I've been to Paris.
I've been to most of the Mediterranean
coast. I've been to Spain.
Where the heck else I've been?
Few other places.
Italy.
All over Italy.
duck fight coming along.
Um, well, I did I did go back and I did
it on leagues recently,
so I actually remember a little bit more
about how everything works.
Obviously, the waves are way easier on
League. The actual Zuck fight was about
the same as the main game though, just
doing it with magic instead of a bow,
but took about the same amount of time.
Still had two sets and everything.
So, that was kind of a nice refresher.
it's pretty close. Like I think it's
almost almost to the point where it
should work.
Not quite there yet.
This is getting to wave six the 60s
here.
It's actually getting to Zuck a little
bit.
We're going to try a couple ablations on
this.
I'm not going to spend a ton of time. We
can spend like half an hour on this.
Didn't we figure out before that this
config does not beat Zuck?
Well, it's not getting to healers either
way.
Why isn't it though? That's kind of
wonky, isn't it?
The only thing I could think of is this
tag reward messing up the waves.
We're going to try this though. I think
this is worth running as an ablation.
I mean, your average run here gets to
Zuck.
This will only make a difference
starting from Jad. So, this will be very
easy to tell if this matters.
Figure out what else we got to do today.
Do we have PRs open? I think we have a
few PRs open.
Okay, I just got to Jad.
Less than 2 minutes to get from one to
Jad is very, very impressive.
The depth of Jad goes up because it gets
there consistently.
Then it's going to go back down
as it learns it.
Tag reward doesn't help
even though it's essential.
because I think having it learn the
final level is harder than everything
leading up to it.
I'm going to just try one thing real
quick. I don't think this is likely to
help, but we're going to try one thing.
We should have found better params than
this.
Okay. So, this is this ain't it.
This did help a little. Well, actually,
no. Oh, wait. No, this didn't help. The
wave start did help.
Let's go grab the parameters from the uh
the sweep on the big box.
All right, there we are.
We'll see what this has found for us.
Well,
looks different.
That's really weird though, isn't it?
Like
still on no threads for some reason. I
don't know why.
changed the damage coefficient, didn't
it?
does it get to kill.
Welcome.
We are currently training an agent
to
beat Runescape's Inferno.
This is a new benchmark.
It's going decently well,
but the final boss is quite difficult
to learn.
I think it is just the boss being too
hard to learn, right?
Maybe that's what we should focus on
because
it doesn't make sense to me.
It doesn't make sense to me that it
should be relatively easy to do all the
waves
and then the ball should be so
ludicrously difficult.
It's like immediately learning to solve
waves, right, in seconds.
Hey, Jess.
Not much. Currently, we are um
we're just looking at the inferno stuff
again.
It doesn't make sense to me how
difficult it is for this thing to fight
Zuck.
I think we probably just need to to mess
with some obs.
That's usually it.
that's a good OBS. That's exactly what
you should have for the OBS.
And then uh we developed the fastest
reinforcement learning tools out there.
You can check puffer.ai.
We have the largest data set of RL
experiments here. We have tons of
environments with models that are
trained you can run in your browser.
from mazes
to autonomous driving. Got games, we got
drones, we have lots of stuff. All free
and open source. You can train
everything locally on one GPU.
If you're new here, I'm an MIT PhD in
RL. I've been doing this stuff for 10
years. I decided it would be a fun thing
to stream all of my research now that
I've graduated and uh I run a small
private lab.
It's all open source. We merge in
environments from contributors.
Um we develop new algorithms. We do high
performance infrastructure. We kind of
do everything.
Oh, yeah. If you haven't seen this
environment, um, this is kind of a fun
one. I don't have a great demo at the
moment. I guess this will do. Yeah, this
will do. So, this is the, uh, inferno.
It's one of the hardest pieces of
content in Runescape. And we have a
simulator for it. And we are training an
agent to do this. It's like this just
brutally difficult gauntlet. It takes
well over an hour for most players to
complete this. And uh we're trying to
train like a superhuman agent on this.
It's going decently well. We just have a
few a few weird things at the moment
that we're dealing with.
This will be like a really nice
benchmark for us to use to improve our
algorithms.
It's a really tough challenge.
This uh this sim was ported from um like
private server code by VO
the contributors.
Yeah, we still have too many of these
metrics.
I mean, we have contributors that are
doing stuff with like 1650s,
though realistically
uh we're doing all of our main research
on 4090s.
And if you want to be able to do that
type of stuff for basically free,
it's so much cheaper than renting the
commodity GP, like the um the commercial
GPUs.
Where is it?
If you just go to this thing
on, where is it?
All right. So, if we just take out data
center chips, because these are
expensive, and we go to RTX cards, and
we just take out the really old ones.
5090s, 37 cents an hour.
Uh 5080s, where is it?
Yeah. Somewhere between like 20 and 40
cents an hour.
You should use our servers for that just
that will get expensive if you do that
type of a thing on vest.
I don't know why this stupid thing is
taking so long to do. Um
Yeah, that'll get expensive. Jess,
that's why we have the hardware.
Use ours.
Okay. Ranger Major.
Uh there actually has been like a pretty
well-known Rocket League RL thing that's
been done. It works quite well. I don't
know about that one specifically if it's
RL or not. You can also do imitation
learning for stuff like that.
Oh, wait. We're on the wrong wave.
We wanted to just do Zach, right?
I've made tons and tons of content on
Puffer. So, the articles tab on my X
X.com/juarez.
It has tons of uh like research
articles, but also intro material. The
docs on puffer.ai have tons of things,
including tutorials.
I don't have a dedicated video yet for
the latest version. I probably will make
one at some point, but I mean really,
the current tutorial should cover it
quite well.
Historical opponent pool is probably
needed.
Yeah, I would believe that, Jess.
I don't understand how it keeps still
dying to Zuck
link
this.
It's Jay Suarez, right? Not J Suarez
5341.
I don't know if I updated it on my
YouTube. I thought I did.
This little trailer is nice
if you wanted just like a 40 second of
buffer.
Okay, we now have about 100% deaths to
Zuck.
for this.
I'll check this version. I think we do
have one.
Ah,
here we are.
We meet again.
Try this.
actually kind of unexpectedly. Um,
this is sort of like unexpectedly
nice as a challenge in the sense that
the boss at the end is kind of
different.
It's at the end of this really long
gauntlet.
The boss on its own is already hard.
Got bruise.
Oh, still just getting smacked by Zuck.
Task you're doing too much for now.
Well, the task I'm doing is this,
right?
It's a game. This is just straight from
Runescape.
It's like this complicated game. Um,
it's this complicated challenge in the
game that requires you to defeat all
sorts of waves of enemies.
And there's a lot of like knowledge you
need to have in order to do this
effectively. And it's kind of just like
a tough benchmark
for our algorithms.
I'm trying to get this working nicely so
that we can use this as a baseline for
the next version of our software.
I think it's dying to healers now.
That's at least a reasonable thing.
Wait, no death to Zuck,
Dad. Ranger Mage. So, what the heck is
killing yet?
Huh?
Wait, what's killing it?
That's better.
What the heck is killing out?
It would have to be healers, right?
Yeah, benchmark is specific for this
game environment. Um, this is just like
a new benchmark, right? We've got 20
plus of these.
This one is one of the more complex
ones.
Um, what policy and reward system are
you using? So, the reward system for
almost the entire in like the entire
event, like almost the entire challenge
is just do damage. The boss is a little
tricky because the boss can heal itself
or there are healers that can heal the
boss. Um, and that kind of lets you farm
reward if you don't mess with it a
little bit. So, that's what I'm handling
now. The policy is our own custom
network. It's based on mining with
highway connections. There's an article
for it on X. It's a tremendously
efficient architecture. We just released
this less than a month ago and it was a
major major breakthrough.
Also, I should just fix my camera now,
right?
This
that
there.
And the buffer
expectation here is that it should just
be dying to healers, right?
Death to healers is.93.
Okay, so that is interesting.
Um, the healers can't actually kill you
that quickly.
So that would mean it's just not
brewing.
That seems weird.
Why would it just not brew
book?
Yes. I mean, if you look at these
articles right here, most of the writing
is here. I have some like formal papers,
but frankly, the formal papers are dense
and really obnoxious. Like this is where
I write stuff that's actually meant to
teach you stuff.
This is my best piece of content right
here. This guide will get you started on
everything you need.
And then all this other stuff up here,
aside from some of these opinion pieces,
like
this, this this like these are all of
our latest research articles. This is
the state-of-the-art in RL.
Yeah, it'll take time. Plasma,
I also so Carpathy's original blog was
good on this, but I think that if you
want like simple, easy to follow RL,
it's slow, but if you want the concepts,
like Costa is the best for this,
Costa's blog on PO, PO tricks, like that
is the core.
>> Yeah. Clean RL.
Clean RL is awesome.
Like the field owes Costa a blood debt
and just doesn't realize it. Like the
field would have just straight died
without clean RL. I even I would have
left. I would have just been fed up with
this field and said, "All right, this
field sucks. Y'all are dumb. None of
this [ __ ] works."
Um,
but I like that was the only clean slate
to start from. That's nice. Like all the
people doing jack [ __ ] now are just
trolling, making a mess. All the big
fancy frameworks are overly complicated
and still slow as hell. Like that is the
only thing out there that's just here it
is. It's simple. It works.
Dad healer damage. Zuck healer damage.
It is tagging the healers. It's just
straight up not brewing.
That doesn't make sense to me.
Why would it just straight up not brew?
It's dying to healers
with a full inventory of bruise.
open end is like this annoying RL thing.
You're not going to be able to do stuff
with that cuz all the LLM RL stuff is
super slow.
Right? Compared to the stuff we do,
you're talking about a difference in
performance of about a 100,000 times.
Like this steps, this is millions of
steps here, right? So I'm running I'm
running 100 plus million steps in a
couple of minutes. And on our faster
environments, I can run a 100 million
steps in seconds.
Uh, I doubt it. But let me try one thing
real quick.
So surely you have to brew a little on
triples, right?
Wait. Bruise used.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is a full
inventory of bruise. It's trolling.
Cool.
Continue training from a checkpoint.
Uh
maybe what is crit?
I mean, honestly, you can PR that crap
in like not any substantial amount of
time if it doesn't,
but um I haven't even bothered because
it's so fast.
Like
The other slightly annoying thing with
four, like if I were to support
continued training from a checkpoint,
I think it would be pretty tough to make
it like you wouldn't get the same
training curve. So Puffer is fully
deterministic right now. Like if you run
the same experiment twice on the same
machine, you will get identical results
like bitwise identical results.
That would be pretty obnoxious to
preserve with loading.
Kind of a different type of RL I would
think,
but yeah, you could
Lovely. Thank you. Hey, star the puffer
on GitHub. It helps a lot. Feed the
puffer a star. He likes stars.
Aren't neural nets non-deterministic?
Well, the softmax sampling, sure, but
you can seed it, dude.
I mean, non-deterministic just means it
uses RNG. Like, you can seed your RNG.
It's a pain engineering wise to get
every single op to be deterministic, but
you can do it. And we did.
Thought it was worth the effort.
It's a pretty nice feature, honestly.
You can make changes and you can tell
immediately if you broke anything cuz
like most changes should not change the
like should not change the outcome at
all.
Thank you very much.
Join the what is it 5.6k stars.
this is from the latest release for the
most part
healer damage.
Okay, so we don't get to zuck healers at
all. Sadly,
we kind of just die to Zuck a lot.
See, now I'm intrigued because I think
we're very close to having it.
So, the way that this fight works on the
Inferno,
let me see if I can find a clip of it.
All right, so this is Zuck.
Okay, it spawns a Jad halfway through.
You have to fight this thing. Where's
the ranger?
Yeah, range mage. So, first you have to
fight these two while you're moving with
the shield, and then you have to fight
Zuck while you're moving with the
shield. And then these healers spawn,
and you have to tag them so they don't
heal the boss. And they also damage you
quite a bit. So, you have to keep moving
with the shield, heal up, whatever.
And then
you might get one more set depending on
how fast you killed it. And then you
have to kill it from whatever HP it
healed back up to.
And there's a bunch of strats like this
is an 18minute guide on just the bosses
you see
by one of the best players in the game.
Now we know how to use bruise,
but maybe we won't die to healers. Maybe
we'll actually drink our bruise.
This is going to be such a cool one to
have done.
but the thing is I don't think that this
is going to be particularly good.
That's cuz the models are not actually
good, man.
What changed your mind?
That was a months ago, man. I don't even
remember.
I didn't think this entropy based method
could possibly be any good.
There was some other stuff with it as
well, wasn't there?
Uh, it's been too long.
I don't like stuff being based on layer
as well. Not critical is good.
I think the conclusion of this is just
that the robotics environments are kind
of [ __ ]
Um, because that's where the benchmarks
are. You always see papers like this on
the robotics ends.
I honestly just don't trust robotics as
a field. They just do too much stupid
[ __ ] constantly.
Okay. Yeah, we can get rid of all the
Runescape crap.
Uh except for this obviously.
I want to watch this one.
Well, hang on.
This one just doesn't freaking brew.
I mean, doesn't freaking brew is not
going to be an interesting reason to
watch for why it dies.
And then we have this one that does
brew, but then
still dies.
A third of the time it just randomly
dies to his plot shot from Zach.
Maybe this is interesting. Maybe this
one is interesting. Hang on.
thing is it still has bruise left.
Shouldn't be dying with bruise left.
And I don't actually think from the
stats it's going to be worth the time to
watch this one.
Now, the rewards for this problem are
very obnoxious
because like you'd like to just say,
"Hey, do damage or whatever," but
they're just a couple places in the
inferno where things can heal other
things. Whenever you have do damage as
the reward and you have healer is there,
then you end up getting a reward farming
loop.
Okay, it's consistently clearing triples
now
Okay,
that's healers.
of wondering if this curriculum works
the way I think it does.
Does it like
as soon as it gets to Zuck at all with
the curriculum,
you should see it see it improve very
very quickly.
And that just doesn't seem to be
working.
Did you run a sweep?
Hey, captain. Long time no see. How's it
going, man?
We have a model that can basically do
the whole thing except for the final
boss. And the final boss is ending up
being quite tricky to figure out cuz um
there are like several opportunities
where the simple reward that you would
define is farmable.
So, we're trying to figure out what to
do.
manually.
Yeah, you probably sweep stuff if you
can. It's easiest.
Just run the default sweep, man. Like
the default sweeps pretty much
everything.
This was re-implemented. It's fast.
Balo ported it from um private server
code.
Okay. So, at least we can see a
difference here.
But without the curriculum, it's way
worse.
I mean, it is just a lot of ticks, I
guess. Like, it's a few hundred steps to
get to healers, even if you start on
Zuck.
I can't understand any of the things I
read.
What are you reading? my articles or
other stuff.
All right. So, the curriculum here,
I believe that this is curriculum junk.
The thing is there's a difference like
we have a lot of M's that have long
episode length
but then the actual gap between pieces
of information is usually way shorter
you know
like you actually get some sort of self
similarity loop that's on a way tighter
frequency than the whole episode length
but with this thing it's just genuinely
several hundred steps
Okay, we're on to Zuck healers.
So, this is 350 steps.
Oo, look at the episode length here.
The episode length blows up.
I wonder if we're like not tagging them
because we're scared or something.
It's not that we're increasing the
reward captain. It's just we're starting
it from different waves.
So, it's built into this specific end,
but the reason we're doing this is
because this is an end where we expect
curriculum to be very important and
Puffer 5 does it automatically. At least
that's going to be the goal of Puffer 5.
So having this as a baseline end of and
getting a feel for what a pain this is
like if puffer five just one shots this
out of the box
I think we've solved
most of the outstanding challenges in
our
four puffer Buffer 4 has been out, man.
Buffer 4 is officially released. Buffer
4 is 20 million step per second
training, the brand new architecture
that um hardware efficient, new
recurrent cell, new connection type.
We've got constellation, the largest
data set of RL experiments. You can play
with it right in your browser
interactively
and get all the hyperparameters, do all
sorts of analysis.
This is uh it's done.
been out for almost a month. I literally
have been gone for like the last three
weeks because it was so much work
leading up to the release. I fried
myself so so badly. Like I have I
basically spent a week I spent a week of
pre-ation if that makes sense. Literally
just unable to move or do anything
meaningful after the release. And then
the last couple weeks I've been slowly
recovering and it's still not all back.
Like all the normal drive that I have is
not there. I just have like baseline
kind of okay back at this point.
That was a crazy crazy amount of work.
And the basic transformer is
it's not a trivial architecture.
Understandable to be confused if you
haven't done previous architecture stuff
before that.
The architecture we use is not based on
transformers for this.
We do um it's mining and highway nets.
Quite a bit simpler.
Got everything we need
covered. Yeah.
I mean, by the end of Puffer 4, I was
basically just like I was spending
energy I really didn't have. I was kind
of just forcing it for the last few
weeks.
So
yeah, it was just dead exhausted
before you should just do CS231N.
Actually, the newer versions of CS231N
probably include transformers, but at
least you'll get like MLPS and cons and
LSTMs and stuff beforehand, I would
assume.
Those
I wonder if there's something screw in
the reward formulation.
I wonder if there's something.
Also, can we fix our pillars
real quick? Let me fix our pillars.
How self play work? Does it need to be
customized?
No, stuff doesn't really need to be
customized. Um, selfplay is not yet
merged into 40. We plan on merging it.
That's been Spencer and Jess's project.
Wait, what?
Aggro target.
Oops.
So, there's a selfplay version of that
you can ask Spencer and Jess about. Um,
but then there's also like a scripted
opponent that you can play against, like
a pretty strong one. And then there's
also like a pre-trained neural net that
only has a few weights that you can play
against.
You can train it with either self player
just against a strong fixed opponent.
That one is very difficult
like as a person. I mean it's very
difficult to play against that.
Wait, why is the episode length so
short?
Yeah. Also, um, if you want to do the
binding port to for over impulse wars,
that'd be great. Captain, I didn't do
the binding port because Impulse Wars
was the only end of that had like this
extra fancy layout.
I don't I'm not super familiar with it.
I didn't want to break it just by
throwing claw at it because you actually
put a lot of work into that.
That makes it kind of tough for me to be
able to p Enough.
Uh, pretty much just if you want to PR a
binding upgrade because Impulse Wars
doesn't work with 40 at the moment. I
didn't upgrade the bindings cuz it's the
only it's the only enemy that has fancy
stuff with make and whatnot
it actually should be a lot faster as
well, right? Cuz like just the load
function and stuff for uh policies is so
much simpler in four. It's just
contiguous weights.
Uh the actual end of side changes versus
300 are very small.
Very very small.
Depends on what you've done though,
right? If you have a bunch of fancy
stuff outside of the spec,
So, but the base is pretty simple.
I don't understand why we're like this,
right?
Why are we not full bastion potted?
Okay, we are full bastion potting now.
Why is our magic level lowered?
And I want to be a researcher. I think
YouTube might have eaten one of your
messages
cuz I only see the second one that's
above here.
That's too long of a fight, isn't it?
500 ticks.
No, actually that's reason. Wait, isn't
that reasonable?
Wars.
It's a pretty cool environment from
Captain. We don't even have it on the
website now because at some point the
build just started crashing people's
browsers. So, it needs a little bit of
maintenance. It's a very cool end.
Maybe we do have it under in progress. I
think I moved it back down to in
progress because it was just straight
crashing people's
Yeah,
it was just straight crashing people's
browsers. But it's really awesome.
Yeah, I don't know how, man. It was the
only end of that would just straight
crash people's browsers.
I'm going to completely and irrationally
blame the make files that you have.
I had it happen a few times on Linux on
uh Chrome.
I had other people say that it would
crash it as well.
Might be some bug reports. We'll see. I
mean I mean on on the issues page on
GitHub, I don't remember.
Just like open the end and it would just
everything freeze.
And I guess I should just watch it at
this point if I don't know what it's
doing, right?
Uh, I don't think he PRD it yet.
I I didn't see a PR from him.
Okay.
Oh,
Uh, no, Captain. If anything, I think
it's going to be way more obvious that
the end needs to be perf optimized
because now our training is way faster.
And at least like almost all the ends
that needed custom networks no longer
need custom networks.
Why is that? Our new architecture is
just way better.
you get way more capacity out of the
base network. So much so that like we so
did a lot of the environments that used
to need custom encoders faster and
without custom encoders.
What? M still neural MMO and I think
drive are still a little iffy.
All right, Zuck.
What do we got here?
What are we doing?
Interesting.
Oh, wait. They're off by one.
Okay, so it is flicking them. Cool.
Okay, that's perfect.
That's like perfectly done so far.
Playing this perfectly. And it's used
what? One bastion dose
109. Yeah, it's good.
We're just going to assume that the
flicks line up because it's not taking
damage and I know for a fact that you
just get wrecked if you don't pray. So,
I think that the Anns might be a little
off, but I know that you just get
wrecked if you pray. Okay, so that's a
heal tag. Heal tag.
It should be getting zero reward for
this
if it's
okay. That's a little off, but that's
not bad.
Okay. It's going to fully freaking kill
the healers. Yeah. Yeah.
I should just cut the reward out for
this [ __ ]
Yeah, I think the it's one tick early on
the jab prayers.
Fellow is right. It's one tick early.
We're kind of just showing off a little
bit here, but this is fine. Okay, so now
we proc he killers, right?
Boom.
Boom. We tag him with twisted bow is not
ideal, but that's still a tag. Okay,
it's procked him in a pretty bad spot.
Okay, that's a tag.
What? Why are we not tagging this
healer?
Why are we taking random Zuck hits
and not brewing?
Huh?
No, no, no, no, no. Something is
completely wrong.
let's set the fight to have Zuck start
at low health.
Uh, I don't think they have that much
health.
Kind of want to try this locally.
Be faster.
All right, I'm gonna be right back.
Removed a bunch of files.
Did I? I didn't think I did. Unless I
moved api file because we no longer
usepi files.
I probably like did that by mistake. If
there's like um actual source code gone,
man, unless you had asset files in
there,
I'll be back.
some of the includes. Oh, um, captain.
So includes
general includes now go in vendor.
I think a lot of the include stuff was
just duplicated and should just be in
vendor.
Uh
well this is weird.
Is everything just going to spawn at
once?
I do wonder if
Well, we'll see on the rewards after
this.
Complicated rewards are always a
mistake.
Uh you could use either mining or
minstm.
I went with mining because if you look
at the minstm formulation,
it's kind of gross. They did this like
this extra weird norm trick in it.
So I felt the mining would just be
simpler to implement for this.
could have used either.
The thing is it's kind of um the name is
kind of wrong like they removed a lot of
what makes those recurrent networks work
in the process of making the min formula
that's parallel scannable anyways.
Also, Mingru on its own doesn't work.
Like, you need the highway connections.
Like, it really does not work on its
own.
It was a pretty sizable difference from
that um that enhancement.
I want to look at the episode return
over this. Did the episode return crash
or did it find a farm?
Farming reward.
So, this is why like this is just a
lesson and stop [ __ ] over
complicating the rewards.
I don't think if there's anything else
we're missing here.
I mean, it can still wait before
tagging.
Going to keep an eye on the episode
return.
Okay, that's four tags.
Now it's getting damage rewards.
Okay, win rate's going up. If win rate
starts going down but return starts keep
keeps going up there's a farm.
100% completion. If this is stable,
we're good.
This will be a jab, skip, healer, skip,
zuck last. Um, yeah,
We'll see if it's stable. 4.2 two with a
one
the first inferno cape that the model
gets is a jab skip healer skip cape.
Let's get the speedun.
I don't know if you can do 65 easily off
task. I think you need a task for that.
All right, it works perfectly.
Eval time.
Boom.
We tag all four of them.
Wait, this is perfection.
This is pure
mechanical perfection.
I have to take a video of this for
vault. I hope my recording tool works.
Wait, hang on. Let's Let's make sure it
works first.
Um, it's crap, man. Like all the AIS,
it's they're all crap.
Oh, wait. The screencast didn't start.
Okay.
I was mainly just sick of giving
anthropic money and I'm mildly less sick
of giving open AI money. Mildly. I tried
Gemini at some point, but that's like
absolutely unusable garbage.
You do need a binding.h. You no longer
need api, captain.
Or it's a binding C now, not a
binding.h, I believe. I forget. Go
check. It's just one file.
It did win, right? I It didn't die.
I didn't see it. Killed it so quickly, I
think.
Oh, yeah. Boom. It wins.
What's the red ball that keeps hitting
the agent? That's That's Jad.
You can actually play this thing
here.
I mean, I can't I can't do this. So,
like I could try to play it, but I can't
do like it's very difficult for me to
describe how hard this thing is.
I'm like a top two to 3% player in the
game
and like I couldn't remotely do that.
I'm going to say the top half% of
players
could do what I just showed you it
doing.
I mean that [ __ ] is tough.
And like to do it as well as it did it
like
What? This look. All right. I can just I
can I can just analyze the gift for you.
So it's going to spawn in. This is the
last part of a boss. All right. I'm just
doing the last part of a boss here. So,
it has to tag all the healers. This
part, it's actually very easy because it
has a lot of grace time when it spawns
in. It has to prayer flick this thing.
So, every time this thing attacks, it
has to react to the animation and change
its protection prayers. Okay? And then
it has to stay behind the shield at all
times. It has to dodge these
projectiles. It has some healing items,
but they lower its damage output. So
once you start healing, you get lower
damage output and it's like a vicious
cycle and then it has to kill the boss
at the same time. So that's like one uh
one, two, three, four. Like you're
paying attention to four different
things at the same time.
It's really really freaking hard. So I I
intentionally set this up as the hardest
possible version of this. When you
normally do this boss, you kill this
thing completely. So, you're only
dealing with this enemy and the shield,
which isn't that bad. And then once this
thing is dead, then you spawn in the
healers, you kill the healers
completely,
and then you kill Zuck. So, you only
ever deal with like two things at a
time. It's dealing with four.
It doesn't seem like the enemy at the
bottom is affecting it much. Yeah,
because it's pre flicking perfectly.
It's actually really difficult to leave
this guy alive because if you leave this
guy alive, you have to do one additional
thing while you're doing all this other
stuff, which is every time he attacks,
you have to look at his animation and
you have to change your prayers.
So changing here, I actually I can use
the online version of their like
Okay, so this is let's see if I go to
wave 67 here.
in this like random online sim.
All right, this is prey flicking.
Whoops.
Don't hit me. All right,
so watch this. This is a ranged attack.
How he just stomped like that. You have
to change your prayer or he can one-shot
you. This is a mage attack. You have to
change your prayer or he can one-shot
you. He spawns these healers once you
start attacking him.
So, you have to be watching his
animation while you also hit the healer
so that they don't fully heal him. You
see how I still have to change my prayer
while I'm doing this.
All right. And now I can kill him.
This alone is not considered a hard
boss. In fact, this is basically the
same as this like um it's basically the
same as this pretty early to mid game
boss,
but then doing it while you're doing all
the other stuff is very hard.
So, this like I I've done four or five
of these. No, I've done four of these at
the same time
before.
And let me tell you that the thing that
I just showed you is a lot harder than
doing four of these at the same time.
The melees are hitting me a little bit,
but it doesn't really matter. All right,
he's dead.
Buffer multitasking to an insane level.
Exactly.
It's really tough to do that. You can go
try the boss on that sim and soon you'll
be able to try it in ours.
All right, here's what we're going to do
next.
We're going to give him his 1200 health
back.
We're going to see if it wins.
That's default encoder hyper swaps.
Now, but here's the thing that's
difficult about this, right? The inferno
is not one fight. The Inferno is 66
waves of fights of increasing
difficulty,
then three boss waves. The first of
which is very easy, the second of which
is quite difficult, and then the final
one is very difficult.
And we can do the entire thing up to the
final boss. We can do the hardest part
of the final boss, but we can't put it
all together yet.
Oh, okay. Got to Chad.
Got to jad once
there.
Well, we'll see what it's failing on
soon.
Uh, this is literally training on my
local machine, man. So, this is training
on the same PC that I'm streaming on and
running two Runescape clients on my side
monitor.
Okay, we tag the mage.
We tag the range.
Wait, this is awesome.
Why is it dying?
This is now the full boss fight.
Oh [ __ ]
Yeah. No, but it's allowed to switch
instantly.
It spams it switches too much, but good
players can switch instantly. If people
complain, we'll give it a smaller
switch.
Like you literally don't even need to
switch on Zuck at all. It's kind of just
doing that for fun.
That's not what makes Zuck hard.
Why Why would you just stand in the
center like that? Why would you do that?
I just watched this thing do a
mechanically perfect.
I just watched this thing do like
mechanically freaking perfect healer jab
skip. Whatever the hell that was.
Are we just going to run out into the
open and die? Yeah. Why are we doing
that?
There's no reason we should be tanking
Zakats
a tanking jad hit. I understand because
it didn't kill anything.
Oh, it just knows it's dead, so it
doesn't care.
I see.
cyber security agent.
I don't know enough about the domain
liberty to know like what type of stuff
that has to do.
arguably also just doesn't
get that much of a penalty I suppose.
The other thing is like by the time you
haven't killed if you have not killed
the ranger.
Wait, can you skip the mage? I think you
can skip the um I think you can just
skip the major on the actual inferno.
But I don't know if we have the ticks
correctly timed for that.
That's cool, man.
That's also very cool that he's sharp
enough to um
to play well.
I've tried to get into chess a couple of
times.
Maybe we're both a little less fried.
Hey, congrats. Yeah, I wouldn't mind
playing a few games at some point.
I mean, I would not be surprised if I'm
like sub 500 ELO quality player. Jess,
It probably just dies before Jad spawns
because um it doesn't want Jad to smack
the shield.
I wouldn't be surprised.
bot going to tournament. Yeah. See if
you can beat the bot.
Okay, now we're going to actually get to
Jad.
Good.
Who plays the champion which is the
boss?
That would seem weird. We tested that
one pretty extensively. I'd be happy to
look at it, but I would imagine that's
got to be like a weird Rail install
thing.
Deleted message usually means they fixed
it.
I think this fight in particular
cuz you don't do in the middle of the
fight curriculum, right?
Yeah, that's probably what to do.
And we've already published four blogs.
They're going to get ported over to the
website eventually. I leave them on X
for a while first so that we get the
views there.
I literally wrote four of them. There's
20 pages of material.
There's a full deep dive on the
engineering, the architecture, the
visuals.
Already done, my friend.
Okay. Kind of cool that we're just going
to flick Jad and um Okay, but we don't
want to flick Jad apparently when we're
doing healers, which is kind of cool.
Wait, are we hitting Zuck?
Yo, why are we hitting Zuck?
Why is it attacking Jad? Wait, why is
there a damage to Jad healers?
Going to try this. See if we can just do
it with this day. of states
I'm going to look that up later. That's
hilarious.
Why are we not fighting Jad?
Speedrun attack.
We see if this just wrecks it.
It should just run over it.
eight months of discoveries.
Yeah,
a lot of stuff.
24 Horizon. Yeah, you can do that now.
It turns out we actually have not seen
um many sweeps really want to push the
horizon, but it does enable some new
stuff going forward.
Yeah, we have some damage on healers
now.
Good. We're no longer fighting Jad
healers for absolutely no [ __ ]
reason. And we're winning.
Curriculum for the win. Easy, easy,
easy, easy mode.
Less than 1 mil SPS here. Really weird
hyperparameters. Captain SIM is also
bottlenecking. So it found
hyperparameters that like spend more
compute on the network because the SIM
bottlenecks otherwise.
Well, I will do some PF optimization on
this.
This is also on my local PC that is
streaming and running two Runescape
clients.
Craft X full.
That looks nice.
Yeah, that looks nice. Vel, let me here.
I'll show you the um the Zuck fight in a
second.
That's going to be pretty fun.
But let me merge the Let me get your
thing.
Wait, is this
something's wrong here, Elliot? Because
this these stats are not good, right?
You have a veck in it now for maps. I
guess
the non-perfs.
Wait, is this now both of them or not?
Like cuz there's craftex classic and
then there's the full one. They're two
different ends. What's this do? Do we
still have them both or no?
I want to make sure I know what I'm
merging.
Also, take a look at this.
We only get 55% win rate. Oddly,
no. You don't want to replace classic
with full Elliot. You want them both for
sure
cuz the the classic one is w more widely
used but should be easily full solvable.
So, wait. Do you have both ends? I'm
confused.
Craft X is classic. Oh, okay. So, you
still have both of them. You just make
Okay, that's good. I will merge that
then.
that's great then.
I've been busy on this project for a
little bit, but yeah, that'll be a new
end to sweep. That'll be good.
I think it had some other assets as
well. So, you grabbed like the uh the
other assets to resources.
After the advice you gave me, the maps
I shouldn't change anything.
Something definitely looks weird with it
though.
Matches on reward level.
Okay, to be fair, Jax has a bunch of
really stupid RNG
and like matching it is a pain in the
ass.
What are we doing here? Why are we not
fighting? Why are we not tagging
healers?
Why are we hitting the ranger and not
tagging healers?
Oh, I know. It's just letting it [ __ ]
heal.
Sorry.
Let me add one thing and I'll merge your
stuff.
Okay, this is merged.
Um, this will be the next like big end
that I do sweeps on after we do the
inferno.
because you keep I keep having to define
extra rewards and it's very difficult to
define ones that are not exploitable.
and now we're winning.
We at 13
the one after inferno. If you look up
crafter
or craft axe,
it's that but fast.
little suspicious the whether we're
farming rewards There
8 by8 lights out. Yeah, at some point.
Currently working on the bigger Ms. I
thought I did run a basic sweep on it. I
forget if I did.
I remembered at least the whatever the
one that you sent me we solved.
I bet you it's still farming rewards
somehow.
I like that it drinks a dose of Bastion
potion.
Like exactly one dose.
Okay,
I don't mind that we're back on Zuck
here.
You do more damage to Zuck than you do
to the Ranger.
Does this deserve noodling? No, it's
not. Oh, and we drank two Bastion
potions for no reason.
Okay, I don't mind us sending healers
here.
Okay, we're very intentionally letting
it heals up,
which is not ideal.
policies. We have a model CU or
whatever.
You don't need custom encoders for
almost anything anymore.
Yeah. So, it's basically just we let it
full heal.
Okay, except the ends, which shouldn't
be CUDA, which you found out, right,
Elliot?
Literally easier and faster to put them
on the CPU.
With the bandwidth optimizations coming
soon, like it'll just be even more that
So, what happens here is it's just going
to get a second set and die, right?
It's going to get a second set
because
uh it let the healers full heal.
Yeah, the spaces are defined in the
binding, right, Captain?
Now, you don't really want to be
optimizing on specific architectures a
ton, Elliot.
Just want to get the end of time near
zero. Get the bandwidth down.
Something manageable.
The only super bad mistake I see is that
we used our bastion potions too early.
I'm surprised we haven't gotten the
second set yet.
Well, I guess we didn't kill Jab,
but surely there should be another set
by now.
But this is why it dies, right? Like it
has to do the entire HP.
Just runs out of bruise.
This doesn't seem like it would be
getting applied then Because
See, now it just refuses to proc
healers.
This is so stupid, man.
It's so stupid.
This is why like reward shaping in
general is just [ __ ] dumb.
Like it's basically impossible once you
have more than a couple of components to
come up with something that's not
exploitable.
Like cuz now it's you're fighting the
reward components.
You just shouldn't be doing this [ __ ] I
have to figure out
What are you actually editing?
Some coefficients, a few fun, a few
lines of logic.
We've literally done that, Elliot. That
also doesn't work because you can easily
create it's like a lot of the time you
create combinations where there's no
possible combination that's not reward
hackable.
No, you can't do that crit because
you'll just never you'll never randomly
beat the boss ever.
You can just run this thing forever.
You'll never beat the boss randomly.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's pretty [ __ ] dumb.
I honestly think that um the policy is
going to be for these like shitty vibe
ported environments.
Obviously, I'm not going to edit 50,000
lines of garbage manually.
But, um I think more and more for our
core code, it's like these models just
suck.
I shouldn't be using them.
See, this is the problem now with having
this code base be like this, cuz I can't
[ __ ] manually edit this, and this
model's [ __ ]
Let me think if there's any other
exploit you could deal with this.
I think no.
I think with this it's good.
And if this works, we'll try the full
thing.
Fine. Why don't we spend a little time
There.
Total healed.
Total damage
there are jobs
for sure. Not as popular as AI. That's
just because there's a glut of money
right now for doing every possible
stupid [ __ ] with language model.
Okay, we have win rate. Is it going to
go up?
Apparently, we're just randomly dying to
Z up sometimes.
So weird to me that that's like not the
first thing that you learn to never do.
At least this is better. We'll watch
this and see if there's anything else we
can improve.
[ __ ] pain in the ass, man. Super
farmable.
We'll see from here.
Okay.
Perfect play so far. Also,
we can put this debug on. Makes it a
little easier to see.
We're going to just take a Zuck hit for
no reason.
Okay, that's just bad hypers or bad
something because there's no like
there's no plausible ex uh there's no
plausible excuse for that.
There's no possible reason, right, to
let it do this otherwise.
I see that sort of reward engineering
crap is really annoying.
It's quite bad in fact that we have to
mess with it. It's funny because it
works. The waves work perfectly without
this
Okay,
cool. So, now we're actually getting to
healers in one minute.
If this is stalling, something else is
wrong.
thing is just completely
dumb. I think is the problem.
Let's just do this.
Bubbles, man. I really, you know,
All this [ __ ] LM code just makes me
really [ __ ] hate programming
sometimes.
It's like I really enjoy my stuff when I
just get to like write stuff cleanly, do
[ __ ] that makes sense, but these models
are just so [ __ ] stupid and then it's
like you just spend all your time
cleaning up [ __ ] rather than
actually thinking.
>> Yeah. Turns out you don't need a bunch
of Python.
And there's no getting it to work with
LMS. The models are [ __ ] dumb.
It's like having code written by your
colleague Jimmy, who's an idiot. There's
nothing you can do that's going to make
Jimmy not an idiot.
Yeah, you'll have to choose a number,
captain,
or have it in like it has to be at least
um
it has to be known at compile time.
What's the purpose?
Well, a lot of the new ones that you'll
see me spending a lot of time on are
hard ends. And then a lot of the time
the ends that we that end up being
useful are not the ones that we expect.
abstract and get the highlight. Nope,
you [ __ ] can't. Because if I can't
predict, if I cannot consistently
predict what Ms are going to be useful
for research, then sure as hell none of
the contributors can. So,
lots of M's, we try them out, we see
which ones are hard, we improve the
algorithms based on what we find. We
continue
No, you're not convert.
If you need curriculum learning to solve
your NV, that's an important thing to
know. And then we'll be able to try it
with 50 without the curriculum learning
and we'll see if it works without.
Okay, even with me missing half the
[ __ ]
this still [ __ ] does better than um
the stupid codeex version.
is fair, Jess.
The problem with that though is that it
rewards your end for being slow and
buggy.
Like you can very easily make dumb
search problems that just require you to
spend compute and there's nothing you
can do about it. As well,
we're not interested in dumb academic
adversarial ends.
Hey, any issues? Vault, the rewards suck
so much for this stupid thing.
Have you seen the thing that I posted,
though?
We're just getting owned by rewards.
I mean, you saw this, right? This was
just the last part of the fight, but
this is a healer skip, jab, skip, duck.
It's just like every possible reward
combination I come up with is farmable.
It keeps just wanting to let the healers
heal Jad back up.
This is probably farmed. Let's see if
this is like farming [ __ ]
This probably tries to kill Jad.
managed to go from single jad to cape.
Okay, that's going to be a nice merge
once we have that. I'm just fixing the
rewards, man. I want to get us a full
like a good model on this.
Oh yeah, the league's progress. Look
what I got yesterday.
Hey there, buddy.
right. Yeah, it's fighting Jad now
because it's getting rewarded for this.
I think we're just going to let it do
the Jad skip.
Um, actions and max sizes. It's for
multi-discreet captain.
How many multi-discreet actions are
there? And then what is the size of
each?
Normal or awakened? Normal. Dude, are
you kidding me?
I did manage to get awakened varorous
though.
I think I will be able to do Awaken
Leviathan in a bit
This is what we want to see.
Why are we not blowpiping these?
Okay, we are blowpiping them now.
Thought it missed tagging one of them. I
didn't say
Let's see if it tries to milk another
set.
It only has a 65% win rate. Apparently,
this agent does.
Apparently 25% of the time it just
randomly dies to Zuck. I haven't been
able to figure out why, man. Like your
obs seem fine to me
here. This should now Jad skip and um
healer skip.
That should turn the That should bring
the app up length down.
I mean, we need this super consistent
cuz we need to do the whole thing. Oh,
yeah. I also I implemented it. It's not
as impressive as it looks because I
implemented um their save states. So
sometimes for the curriculum, it starts
from Jad or it starts from healers. So
that was important.
I figured we may as well just do that to
make it re like reasonably approachable
cuz puffer five should eliminate that
anyways.
I kind of figure once you're done with
current project, I'm going to hopefully
have you a good model and then you can
fine-tune and play with it. Um,
and then hopefully we can like we can
put together a demo and then we'll have
a comparison when we do Puffer 5 later.
I want to see like the full full uh
cape.
100% full cape completion rate. That
sounds good.
Okay, it's starting to win after only a
minute and a half.
I mean, it's pretty damn hard for people
to be fair.
And you do see occasionally people tank
a zuck shot uh a zuck hit and just get
one shot. It does happen.
Oh yeah, Vault, I still had to move the
pillar. Um, the pillar prevents you from
attacking the ranger. I don't know
what's wrong with the logic, but I can
confirm that like the [ __ ] just doesn't
work if you don't move the pillar.
You just die to the ranger or the ranger
kills the shield and then Zuck smacks
you.
So
that's a thing.
All right, let's see why this why like
this stupid agent is losing.
You might have fixed it in your main
branch. I'm on this merge healer thing.
Oh yeah, we just get a zuck hit for no
[ __ ] reason. Of course.
Let me make sure this still runs and
then we'll try the full thing.
um sort of vault. Some of the sweeps
have kind of just sucked.
Okay, this one is decent.
It still just randomly tanks zits.
I think realistically, vault, we
probably just need to like we probably
need to mess with the reward scales
because the max for negative reward is
it's a max of negative one.
Like it just probably doesn't care
enough that it dies.
But we also have to make it not just sit
behind the damn pillar the whole thing
as at the same time.
learned a ton though. Oh yeah, there
will be more. There will be more to
learn as well.
You will see
the 5L curriculum stuff is going to work
really well for this do it properly.
I'm going to let this run.
Yeah, I'm going to let this run.
Something reasonable here.
One,
five,
Let's add to 1 2 3
5 75%
improvement inside very soon. Jess,
very soon.
Probably even start a little this week.
Okay.
Uh I'm
Let's do one other Thank you.
My vechanit
in it is called in both. So, oh yeah,
captain. So, for veinet, uh, most m just
define that for you and it just loops
through and calls your init on all ends.
Uh the custom one is for if you have to
do like shared logic across ends and
then you're responsible for calling in
it yourself and wiring up pointers and
[ __ ]
Most don't need one. But if you're doing
like shared map generation and stuff
then you need a shared in
Hey, Spencer. Yep.
Um,
it's just really reward hackable as it
turns out. It's really tough to have
this one not be reward hacked.
I think we're going to be able to get
something with a bunch of like manual
curriculum stuff.
I think we're going to be able to get it
with like some manual curriculum and
stuff. Um, but then this will be a great
test for five.
Use the restroom real quick. I'll be
right back. I'm going to train a quick
model.
No wins
50.
doesn't get to Zuck.
Well,
solo a bit next week.
The portal will probably be painful. I
actually think learningwise it'll just
be way easier.
animations are fixed in main.
All right, I will get that.
See? Yeah, it's just farming [ __ ] off of
these.
Yes, it does mess up the whole thing. If
uh you make the penalty too small, the
model ignores it. If you make it too
large, the model refuses to proc killers
and suicides if it does by mistake.
Oh, look. It actually gets to
Zuckillers. So this is uh wave one to Z
healers
in three three minutes something. I
think this might be sweepable.
Let's see Val starting from um single
jab.
And if nothing is obviously being farmed
then uh this will be our progress for
the day on this one.
Why am I putting my headphones on?
I think we can probably get rid of the
healer rewards.
posting the model a lot.
Um
Yeah, it's one tick off in this version.
Like you said, the jabs
damage is supposed to get um cal when
the when the projectile appears. I'm
pretty sure not the tick before.
So, like it should be missing the prayer
right there. And I was I keep wondering
like why the hell it looks like it's
getting hit, but it's because the um the
jabs are a tick Really?
See if I can get it to do something in
the meantime.
melee pathing.
I see
You sometimes kind of do need to brew
for triples, right?
Depending on the melee RNG,
assuming you're not weaving blood barges
in while flicking jabs.
I don't know. Can't your bow just noodle
really hard and you just keep getting
melee?
I want to see what it does on Zuck. Then
I want to see if we um
we manage to fix the uh this cuz this
takes forever because it's full killing
healers.
Three healers hitting.
You can totally have three healers
hitting though, can't you?
Yeah, I don't know why it takes Zuck
hits the thing. It's like way easier for
it to learn to flick than it is to learn
the shield.
You are on the wrong side of the arena,
aren't you?
You are on the complete wrong side of
the arena, my dude.
Didn't
totally get there in time. Okay, you got
there in time.
Oh, I noticed it's out of bruise
actually in the training run. It could
just be out of supplies for Zuck.
Yeah, there's a pretty heavy penalty for
taking shield damage.
There is vault. I There's a penalty for
the shield getting damaged.
I think we still need to put some time
into this. I'm fine spending a good
amount of time on this today if it's
Don't get hit by Zuck here. Okay, good.
Come on. Let's see what this looks like.
It looked like it was off to me, but
maybe it wasn't.
Um, yeah, I need to mess with the
rewards, man. It's getting rewarded for
the damage to the healers. So, it's just
a farm.
That's the next experiment is going to
be turning that back off.
It really does. I don't think it knows
healers yet. Let's see.
Okay.
Okay. It's tagged all the healers.
That's correct play.
Well, does prayer does prayer count on
the first tick that you have the prayers
up in this or can you flick
Yeah. So, what's happening? Cuz this one
didn't get the cape at all during
training. So, it's just running out of
supplies.
Let me get rid of the jab healer rewards
because it's losing a couple minutes to
jad healers.
So that's probably it's losing like
maybe even a full restore to Jad
healers.
And then the curriculum, I think it has
too many supplies in some parts. It's
learning to be too aggressive with its
supplies.
to do dev end now.
Yeah, puffer tank is goodn
and ncccl. Yeah, so that's why puffer
tank. We have a 40 container for puffer
tank shipped.
Easier with jad timing and melee pathing
fixes.
Let me get it stable vault and then I
will do the thing where I like pull your
thing into the branch. I'll do that.
Yeah, curriculum supplies would be good.
I'm going to fine-tune the inventory a
little bit. I think I think it might
need an extra brew.
I mean you basically guaranteed need
like two of them, right?
you like you need at least a brew or two
for healers.
You probably need a brew for triple
healers
unless you're good with blood barrage.
We not getting to Zuck now with that.
That'd be so weird, man.
We have no bruise. Oh, we are getting to
Zuck. Okay.
It depends when it uses them, right? If
it uses them early, it's kind of
screwed.
I think having zero bruise for going
into Zuck is
that's pretty tough.
I don't know. They're definitely
situations where the correct thing to do
is to use some supplies.
Okay, we just let the healers full heal
it.
Okay, I know what's wrong with it. We
can fix this.
I forgot you can technically just do
that, right? I guess it doesn't need
bruise for that either.
Wait, shouldn't this reward work?
Oh, it doesn't work for Jads.
So, the way that I figured out how to
make it tag the healers and not let it
heal up is um
uh it
you get less you get proportionally ally
less reward
if the healers healed Zuck or healed Jad
whatever. So like even though it has
more HP once it's healed up you get less
reward for it.
This was the only non-exloitable thing I
could come up with.
That way we don't have it doing jank
cape, you know.
here. Let's see if this gets it through
Jad quicker.
Okay, we get to jad
7 seconds.
A lot of deaths to Jad
not getting to Zuck.
That means I probably broke something.
Oh no, we do get to zuck
barely.
It's getting to Zuck with a Brudos and a
re and like a restore and a half Oh,
Okay, that's a good tag, right? Hey, you
forgot one, you [ __ ]
it kind of screwed up the tag a little
bit, but it did try.
Yeah, you have to build for the end of
that you train on captain.
Uh, in that case then you have the wrong
you probably have two local
installations. Then try python-m
pufferlib.pufferl.
It's probably running the wrong one.
Write a table.
Okay.
Well, these jabs look cleaner, right?
Yeah, it just camps melee prayer and
then it flicks for the uh the tick.
Okay,
minus one.
I think we keep this
because this looks better for um Jad's
looks better for Jads.
I don't know why it likes to run super
far away.
It's missing ticks as well to run super
took a jad hit there.
I mean, it's doing this stupid [ __ ]
running super far away for some reason.
There's got to be a reason it's doing
this. We see this consistently.
Now we'll Now we'll tag healers, right?
Yeah, that's healer.
Okay. Run around healers is like
reasonable at least. You don't get hit
me. You don't get hit melee off tech.
Um, vault. Why' the shield go to the
left?
Can it do that?
I thought it always starts to the right.
It's 50/50.
Well, it just got zucked.
That's sketchy.
Real game.
I thought it went to the right for some
reason.
I mean, realistically, you should have
plenty of shield health either way.
still does 1.5 laps.
I don't know.
Make sure that this can still do the
bosses.
Come on. Tell me I didn't break the
Oh, okay. Hang on. That was healers.
I guess. Is it the EP length? Yeah, the
EP length is super long, right?
was just [ __ ] around on Jad for some
reason.
Yeah, it's not getting enough
experience, I would think,
on Zuck because it just [ __ ] around on
Jed.
And now it's starting to learn, but now
it's too late.
Like if I just do this,
this works.
Why does it do that, man? And it just
[ __ ] around
like
Just want to see if without the jad
waves
we do the full
I just want to see if it's like the Jad
thing is the thing that's [ __ ] it
over.
The triples really were not bad. I think
I died to them once in my cape because I
had no prayer potions left. No restores.
Still no wins.
Okay. So, it's not the the Jad screwing
us over
and
Yeah, it's not the judge screwing us
over.
Okay.
1 15
five
six
There's a restroom and I will be right
back.
We will see if this does anything. I
think we're going to have to sweep.
It's very weird to me how like
it seems the waves are much easier
all the compute really just goes into
Zuck, which seems wrong to me. I would
think like when I was thinking about
this project, I figured it would just
one-shot Zuck and the waves would be
hard, but it's like one-shotting the
waves and then Zuck is hard.
What's your chair?
It's like a recliner lounge chair thing.
Okay, we are getting to Zuck. Oh, hang
on. Wait. We are doing Zuck reasonably
here, aren't we?
Very logical. Yeah. Oh, that's it.
That's the cape. Well, that's the cape
from one. That's it.
It just I just saw it. That was the cape
from scratch.
That's first inferno completion from
scratch.
Wait.
Okay. It's not a sub hour cape cuz the
episode length is the mean. I don't know
how many ticks it takes to get the cape.
We'll get a reasonable win rate when we
do the eval.
Uh it's big because only only 20% of the
data is being logged right now because
80% of the data is on curriculum resets.
So it's like 5x swingier
than other ends would be
here. This eval will give us a
reasonable completion rate.
with heavy curriculum but the cape from
scratch. Um,
Yep.
Okay. This is sweepable.
This is sweepable.
Damn it. Did I have Zuck on 239 health?
[ __ ] man.
Maybe I hadn't compiled that version.
Hang on.
That doesn't seem right to me because
the logs Hang on. We might still be
safe.
Duck remaining health is showing at
1,200 and it looked like this earlier.
We might be fine. I do have to rerun it.
That's only six minutes. It's fine. If I
didn't [ __ ] it up, then this is
sweepable.
Why can you register an email?
That doesn't seem like you should be
able to
I'm pretty sure vaults it's all crap.
Actually, what you should do is you
should just do this and just mute them
all
thing that's annoying is I can't even do
not interest this dude.
Okay, we just got to Zach halfway
through.
Yeah, the health starting at 1,200. I
think it I think it was fine.
Nerds on my feed. Yeah, that is the
goal.
Wait.
Crap. Is it different now? We have zero
damage on healers.
Yeah, this is just the weirdass jank
params that the sweep found.
If this doesn't work, I'm just going to
run it for longer.
I don't believe that it's like
it can't do the first part of the Zuck
fight, right?
Why are we doing 900 damage to Jad
healers?
There's We fixed that thing. Damn it.
There's not even reward for that.
Unless it's trying to heal off of them
cuz it's out of bruise.
Oh, we were at healers, man. That's
[ __ ]
And then there's something screwy here
as well because
Why does this model rate more highly
than the previous model that actually
won?
That seems wrong.
It was maybe skipping too. I don't
That's weird.
course
[ __ ] with this.
Why is it like this, man? I didn't Okay,
I just have to stop using these models.
Even on this, like even though this code
base is AI, it's like more AI doesn't
make it better. It just makes it worse.
[ __ ] this is awful.
Let's do the hardest part of the Zuck
fight.
Does the hardest part of the Zuck fight,
but it can't get there really.
and I was I thought we had the damn
cape.
I still don't know if we have any weird
farm bug though.
The problem
Like why do we suddenly have 500 damage
on Jad healers?
curriculum supply skilling?
There's checkpoints.
Okay,
good.
I just need to pull this and start it on
suck, don't I?
I don't see how we have an appreciable
fraction of deaths to Zuck
Yeah. See, this doesn't make sense to
me.
It would learn this like instant,
wouldn't it?
Okay, I guess we're going to have to
copy it over.
it's got to be learning something very
Stupid.
Why are we tanking Zuck shots? Why are
we just dead?
What is this product? So this is wait
20 mil.
You only get like 10 full runs of the
inferno on this is the problem.
Even with a perfect policy, it actually
takes it like 20 30 mil steps just to
catch up.
Is it 20 30? Yeah, 20 to 30 mil steps to
I mean, wave 53 means we're dying the
majority of the time on the waves,
right?
It's getting 20% of the data from the
start, 30% from starting wave 50. I
shouldn't say of the data, I should say
of the runs.
Hopefully this does something better.
A little bit more of the data on Zuck.
This doesn't work. I'm going to have to
change it more.
whole die instantly to Zuck thing is
[ __ ]
There's got to be some reason. It's just
dying instantly behind Zuck, right?
I hate that I have to keep resetting
this, but like
I can only think that it's like that
we've seen this solved so easily that I
think that there's just a reward
mismatch.
I think it's honestly just suiciding.
And this is why rewards in general like
this reward engineering things just
sucks. And we need to get way way more
towards the automatic curriculum stuff
because this is [ __ ]
I mean I think that if we consider
this is a high complexity end to be
There.
Learning rate schedule thing's kind of
funky.
I wouldn't be surprised that we get a
lot out of just like learning rate warm
up and stuff like That
Dad,
I'm not going to keep doing these manual
experiments. I think I'm just going to
sweep it and call here.
It's just annoying because the sweeps
really haven't been doing much for me.
vault at the moment. Like I think that
there is a genuine
reward hack in it.
rewards.
Um,
I think that we should probably be able
to do that. We'll be able to do that for
all of the waves,
I would think, with puffer five. I don't
know about Zuck.
Oh, see this is a more principled thing.
This is a reward hack for [ __ ]
See that just gets clipped to one guess.
So
It will help a lot vault if we do it
right.
Okay, we don't even get to [ __ ]
healers.
Okay. We will see if this runs.
Uh league progress update.
We got this gear.
We got uh
42 mil mining.
50 mil. 50 mil.
32 mil. 50 mil.
Almost 50 mil in the combats.
Gotten four pets.
I think four pets. Three or four pets.
No, four pets in the freaking league
and 34k points
almost to run.
Lots of tasks to do.
max soon. Yeah, I was thinking about
that
thing I can get for free from the
butler.
Cooking is half an hour.
All right, I gotta go.